at seven foot two NBA legend Kareem
abdul-jabbar's not only towers over most
people he also sits atop the NBA's
all-time leading scorers list with more
than 38,000 career points 38,000 387 to
be exactly the former Los Angeles Lakers
star is known for his trademark skyhook
that shot helped him win six
championships over his 20-year career
abdul-jabbar's now an executive producer
of the new History Channel documentary
black Patriots heroes of the revolution
it highlights significant
african-americans who stood up to
British rule and helped establish this
country I first learned about the the
Rhode Island regiment after I retired
from professional basketball and the
thing that impressed me the most about
them was the fighting spirit of people
who are getting an opportunity to make
themselves free they have to do it by
fighting you'll see the most ferocious
determined people in the world that are
proving themselves that way and Kareem
abdul-jabbar joins us good morning
welcome good morning what drew you to
the Revolutionary War period
specifically I think just living in the
part of Manhattan that I was raised in
it was last parked at George Washington
held on - before he had to skedaddle
down to Valley Forge and I realized that
happened in my neighborhood Wow and it
kind of it has always drawn me in
there's a old Dutch farmhouse on
Broadway at two hundred and third Street
that gentleman that owned that farmhouse
had slaves didn't find that out until I
was an adult one of the things you say
in the documentary is that this is kind
of corrective to the history books you
had - and this is your phrase deal with
growing up and I think it's so
interesting because it suggested like
the history you're being taught is not
necessarily the history capital H no
it's not complete for sure I think the
history that we're taught is it's taught
to us in a way that kind of minimizes
all marginalizes the contributions of
people who are not of European descent
yeah and I think that that that's that's
the problem
they're only focusing on one segment of
society and what they contributed and
were you actually saying the doctor
could not have won the Revolutionary War
without the contribution of black
Americans but in success in the war
would come whoever armed blacks the
fastest talk about the role because I
learned so much watching it yes the
manpower shortages have affected both
the revolutionary side and the British
side so they both needed to have people
for reinforcements and to support just
to do the menial things that enable an
army to win and that required manpower
and slaves who are idle on the side were
considered to be a valuable source of
manpower and owe a lot more than what I
was taught yeah because I wasn't taught
anything yeah you you you make reference
to a couple of key figures of poet
Phyllis Wheatley and james Armistead
Lafayette yes Armistead Lafayette was
wildly crucial he got the information
that enabled the Revolution enabled
George Washington to pin Cornwallis on a
peninsula and he was stranded and that
defeat really just tired the people in
England they said we've had enough of
this man he was a spy for the
Continental Army yeah yeah and he
enabled them to understand exactly what
to do at the right time why did you feel
it was so important to tell these
stories that you were not seeing in
history books
I think it's blindly important in
America because black kids are raised
without understanding that this is their
country they think if this country was
established for people other than them
and that they are seen as marginal and
of no use
certainly marginalize and minimize
that's why I think this is so important
I like how you start the documentary it
says a life is not important except for
the impact it has on other lives when I
heard that line it certainly made me
think about Kobe Bryant who I know was a
very good friend of yours and you knew
the family very well where does Kobe sit
with you how important was he to you
I think Kobe was very important
especially to his generation yes I mean
he left high school and took a chance on
being a professional athlete risky he
did it in style and absolutely was a
figurehead for the kids in his
generation who are adults now and just
the fact that it's such a senseless loss
we didn't that didn't need to happen yes
I think that's the worst part of it for
me I remember Indiana I used to play
peek-a-boo with her six years old you
know I was coaching I'd see her all the
time
yeah that's how it affected me you know
played against Kobe's dad right yeah
jelly and I used to go in you know in a
very old days you know they're talking
about records being broken LeBron is
just surpassed Kobe and now you're
you're still the number one scorer are
you sitting there thinking no you can
stop now or are you thinking records are
made to be broken they are made to be
broken and they give us an idea of where
we've gone and where we're going right
do you keep track of those numbers no I
don't know more power to LeBron when
whenever he breaks it if he wants to
because he could be someplace counting
his money yeah he's got a lot to count
right yeah so he could be doing that but
he's doing great things yes and I just
wanted to keep doing it yeah do you
believe he won't break it
he's got a great shot you never know
there's an injury out there or there's
not you know yes yeah that's what you
watch what do you think Kareem three
million people have changed the signed
the petition to change the NBA logo to
the image of Kobe we're doing another
great Laker Jerry West by the way whose
silhouette was there what do you think
about that I don't I you know I don't
get into that because we need to
remember Kobe in a lot of ways that
people aren't talking about you know the
fact that he was interested in women's
athletics and promoted that that I
thought that was remarkable and totally
unexpected from somebody in his position
yeah he was a big supporter of the WNBA
and they said if Kobe went maybe he
would make people see how great this
game is and the talent that the women
have that he was a high profile NBA
player
sitting there on the sidelines sharing
the women on because mattered to him and
I think by encouraging women's athletics
we've really done a lot for the females
in our country that need have something
to aspire to no my granddaughter now is
thinking about playing softball and I'm
that's awesome yeah all right cream well
thank you very much very much this is a
series I understand that you and Deborah
Morales Oh co-producer I want to do this
I'm working with history and we're gonna
be doing some other things I got I have
other ideas and they've been open to it
very nice working with the people at
history they're great people off to a
good start
all right thank you thank you very much